an officer responsible for training
cadets at the Citadel military college
is under arrest charged with sexually
abusing a student
Lieutenant Colonel Kenneth Bose appeared
in front of a South Carolina judge
yesterday after turning himself in to
police a 20 year old male cadet accuses
Bose of abusing him multiple times in
one instance the cadet claims most
perform sex acts on him after supplying
him with alcohol and unidentified white
pills it poses on campus residents we
were at the Citadel yesterday where I
spoke with the school's head of
communications Colonel John Dorian about
the allegations
Colonel Bose was a TAC officer that the
duties of attack officer and a train
advise and coach our cadets and now he's
accused of a sex crime
I mean how upsetting is that for people
here at the Citadel well it's deeply
disturbing colonel Bose had worked here
for quite some time
the Sidel is absolutely committed to
making sure that we have the safest
possible learning environment but it's
very tough it shakes our our community I
also asked colonel Dorian whether
they've checked the files to see if
there were any other complaints against
this officer he says they are not aware
of any other allegations or complaints
against him you're right to ask the
question what is the impact on morale
for everyone there at the base and the
students there they'll be investigating
to you Nora thanks